[Müzik]
Evet Teşekkür ederim herkese
merhaba Benim için keyifli bir ziyaret
oldu
Samsun Aslında yaptığım işlerden hepiniz
Sizler de öyle değişik şapkaların var
anneyiz babayız üniversitede hocayız
mentor koşucu atleti işlerimiz var Benim
de öyle Eee bunlardan bir tanesi şu an
halihazırda yürüyen bir projeye Avrupa
Birliği projesine
Eee ekipte yim ekip lideri olarak ilginç
O proje az bir şey de belki sona doğru
bahsetmek istiyorum Çünkü biraz
inovasyon girişimcilik diyenler olabilir
Bayağı da genç bir ekip Var gibi
gözüküyor Onların da istifade
edebileceği noktalar var eee Eee
smartnet Global şimdiden söylemiş olayım
Bir Boş zamanınızda bakarsınız İlginç
olan şu E bu genelde bu tip büyük
projeleri önemli platform işlerini Ya
istanbul ya Ankara'daki böyle büyük
danışmanlık şirketleri kazanır ama bu
projeyi Samsun merkezli Swan leiko
adında bir şirket kazanmış Okan Bey'i
tanırsınız belki bazılarınız tanır Okan
Gümüş Eee o krediyi de oraya teslim
etmek istedim o projeyi yürütüyoruz
Bugün hem kendi tecrübem
ışığında hem de dünyada ilginç şeyler
oluyor beklediğimiz hiç beklemediğimiz
sürprizler oluyor bunlardan birkaç
tanesini şöyle
söylersek pandemi ve pandemi
sonrası yaşanan dönemler işte reset
dendi içinin ne olduğu bilinmediği hala
tartışılıyor Arap baharı yaşadık darbe
girişimi yaş adık bir anda kendimizi
Rusya Ukrayna Savaşı'nda
bulduk yani sanırım zaman ve mekan
daralması bunun özeti zaten daha önceki
konuşmacılar da değişime Dem vurdular
teknoloji Ben de biraz
değişim meraklısıyım
araştırıyorum okuyorum zaman zaman
düşüncelerimi kaleme alıyorum kaleme
aldığım şeyler pek okunmuyor onu
söyleyebilirim kitabımın hep kendi
başına iflas Diyebiliriz ama yazmaya
devam ediyorum şimdi değişim
deyince geçmişime alakalı da söylendi
bir 15 yıl yurt dışında çalıştım şanslı
yerlerde bulundum genelde hayatta şansa
inanırım şanslı olduğumu düşünürüm hele
son 40'tan
sonra daha pozitif düşünmenin önemini
kavradım ama deneyimsel ve düşündükçe
Aslında iyi insanlar iyi projeler işte
Okan Bey de veya onun projesi de öyle
geldi beni buldu iyi şeyler karşınıza
çıkıyor ya siz onları görmeye
başlıyorsunuz ya bir enerji var
bilmiyorum enerjiyle ilgili bir iş E
bunu ölçüp biçemedim ama
Eee özellikle teknoloji dediğimizde
girişimcilik inovasyon inovasyonu hayata
geçirebilmek eyleme dönüştürebilmek
dediğimizde bu iş dünyasının hemen her
yerinde belki haın da geniş
katmanlarında pozitif düşünmeyi tekrar
bir düşünmenizi isteyeceğim bugünkü
etkinliklerden sonra ne kadar pozitif
düşünüyorsunuz ya işte hayata böyle
bakamayız Gerçekler var Ben o gerçekleri
görmeyelim demiyorum ama o hızlı değişim
içerisinde
kartlar her daim tekrar tekrar
kırılırken o pozitif bakış size çok
ilginç bir koridor Açabilir benim
hayatım da açtığını söylemem lazım onun
için
memnunum şimdi değişimi nasıl ölçeriz
yani İnsanlık tarihi boyunca her an her
şey değişiyor yani coğrafyalar değişiyor
toplumlar değişiyor
e Aslında iş sektörler alanlar ürün
Hizmetler çok hızlı değişiyor Peki o
hızı nasıl ölçeriz derseniz son dönemde
buna şöyle
bakıyoruz artık bilgi
en fazla bilginin ayak izi depolama
dijital veri işte büyük veri Yapay Zeka
veri toplayıp işlemek bunları öne
çıkarttık söylüyoruz onun ayak izi de
depolama yani sizin email ellerinizde
SMS olarak tuttuğunuz mesajlarda
WhatsApp'ta bankaların büyük Hava
Yollarının veya uzay çalışması yapan
bilimin bilim dışı bütün sektörlerin
Aslında Kolektif datası bir yerlerde
tutuluyor serverlar dediğimiz sunucular
binlerce on binlerce serverın olduğu
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde de çok
büyükler var Başka yerde de var tabii
oralara bakıyorum yani genelde çöle
koyuyorlar Çünkü metrekare
pahalı çok fazla kişi olmadan on
Binlerce yüz binlerce serverı yönetmek
mümkün ama bunlar ısınıyor bunları
soğutmak lazım gene enerjiyle ilgili ve
İşte o karbon emisyonu fakat değişimin
hızını anlamak için şunu söyleyelim
bugün 2nin 70 kuvveti kadar bir dijital
veri ve Eskiden 2030 yıllık dönemlerde
iki katına çıkarken şimdi 4 yılda iki
katına çıkıyor yani haspel kadar birimiz
bir 4 yıl burada olmasak döndüğümüzde
yarı insan oluruz bilgi seviyemiz
itibariyle
teknolojik anlamda onların ürüne
dönüşmüş haliyle birçok uygulama
gelebilir apayrı yaklaşımlar söz konusu
olabilir ve biz yani hani kimseye Allah
göstermesin 4 yıl Yattık kalktık
kendimize geldik veya uzaya gittik
geldik böyle bir durum söz konusu
olabilir İnsan bir boyutuyla çok
konformist Hatta statü koy ama bu bunun
oturduğu düzlem daha yüksek bir gelir ve
refah seviyesi yakalamak
Demek ki Fransa Almanya İsveç belli
ülkelerle yakalayabilmek için bu farkı
kapatmamız lazım Burada da büyük bir
istek olduğunu söyleyebilirim istek ve
iştah Türk insanında ve Türk kobisi de
şirketlerinde büyük şirketlerinde Hatta
kamus unda da olduğunu
söyleyebilirim büyüyerek hızlı büyüyerek
farkı kapatma isteği ve iştahı var işte
bu bizi biraz nereye
getiriyor burada bugüne kadar
yaptıklarımız sonradan oyuna girdik
mesafeyi kapatmaya çalışıyoruz ama Acaba
bunu daha yenilikçi ve işte sağ lop sol
lop söylendi burada biraz daha
multidisipliner ve kadını da bugüne
kadar belki Arzu ettiğimiz katılımı
katılım ortamını
yaratamıyorum larımız ister istemez
Tabii
üniversite odaklı bir
yaklaşım yani Belki 5 yıl sonra 7 yıl
sonra bir üniversite hocası olarak
akademinin üniversitenin
kalmayabilir söyleyiş şekliyle burada
udemy'den eğitim almış kim vardır
ücretli veya
ücretsiz yarı yarıya gibi gözüküyor
Demek ki herkes biliyor o bir Türk
şirketi idi bugün Amerikalı bir şirket
iki kurucu Az daha bırakıyordu
Çünkü kullanıcı yoktu ve yatırım imkanı
yoktu 10 yıl önce fakat Amerika'da
yeşerdi bugün piyasada borsada işlem
gören 5 milyar dolar piyasa değeri olan
nitelikli bir şirket belki üniversite
kalmayacak ama en azından bugün
itibariyle üniversite odaklı Bakmak
istedim sadece istatistikleri size
söyleyeyim
Bugün üniversitelerimizde kamu Vakıf
hepsi dahil Profesör seviyesinde tahmin
ettiğimin biraz daha altında kaldı kadın
oranı 66 erkek % 34 kadın ama
gittiğimizde hep görüyoruz kadınlar iyi
varlık gösteriyor demek ki Profesör sev
Esi henüz değil ama doçente
baktığımızda 59'a 41 hemen kadında bir
iyileşme var bir altına geldiğimizde
daha genç olarak Doktor
unvanlı 47'ye çıkıyor 47
Peki öğretim görevlisi dediğimizde kadın
öne çıkıyor 52 ile %
52 araştırma görevlisi % 53 Demek ki
genç kuşak Kadınlar en az eşit veya daha
fazla bunlar ileride Doçent Profesör
daha fazla oranda olacak bu
sevindirici bugün toplam her seviye
bütün akademisyenlere
baktığımızda aşağı yukarı 53'e 47 böyle
bir dağılım ama gençler daha fazla kadın
bu sevindirici bir de şeye bakalım Eee
üniversite
öğrencilerimiz işte ikinci eee öğrenim
birinci öğrenim işte uzaktan bütün
hepsine baktığımızda 10 milyona Aşkın
üniversite öğrencisi var yani 10 milyon
demek Avrupa'daki bazı ülkelerden daha
büyük bir nüfus burada önemli bir hamle
olduğu söylenebilir kalite
tartışılabilir ve söylediğim gibi 5 10
yıl içerisinde üniversitenin anlamı
değişebilir yitirebilir ama yine de
bugünkü durum itibariyle rakamlar şunu
gösteriyor
kadın
öğrencilerimiz yüksek lisans doktoraya
da dahil
edersek 50'den biraz daha fazla Demek ki
o işte Daha sonra araştırma görevlisi
doktorasını tamamlayacak doktorada Belki
birkaç bin erkek daha fazla ama sayılar
kötü değil Biraz da şeye bakmak
istiyorum bu kadar bizim
Arge merkezimiz var 1200 civarında 300
civarında
Eee tasarım merkezi var bu 1500 16600
üst kamunun onay verdiği büyük
şirketlerin Arge veya tasarım
merkezlerinde
Eee kadın oran daha yüksek Örneğin ben
bir başka programda tch exle
girişimcilik programında bir kadın
Başkan e Birlik başkanı ihracatçı Birlik
başkanı tamamen kadınlarla çalışıyorum
tesadüf Onun bir yansıması olarak her
yıl 50 tane Arge merkezini ziyaret edip
analiz yapıyorum karşıma oturan müdür
uzman mühendis araştırmacı % civarında
gene Arge merkezleri çalışanlar zaten
daha yüksek Emek anlamında Arge
merkezlerinde böyle bir oran olduğunu
söyleyebilirim yine ilginç bulduğum için
dikkatinize getirmek istiyorum mesela
patent
sahipliği Çünkü değişim demek
teknolojiyle inovasyonla yeni bakış
açılarıyla sanatla oluyor E o zaman bu
değişim içerisinde patent bir Tabii ki
gösterge olabilir Çünkü o patentlerin
bir kısmı ticarileşen biliyor şirkete
dönüyor startup oluyor
OECD ülkeleri
arasında Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri Almanya dahil birçok ülkeyi
geçiyor Türkiye 6
sırada yani patentlerin sadece
Türkiye'de sadece %
116 bir kadının adına
tescilli ama % 166 ile yani dünyanın bu
alandaki durumu da öyle çok çok parlak
gözükmüyor onu da söylemek isterim yani
bu oranların Tabii % 30'lara 40'lara
gelmesi lazım biraz daha yönetim Eee
dediğimizde biliyorsunuz fırsat eşitliği
aynı işi yapıp aynı ücreti ödeme
noktasında Japonya mesela bütün
gelişmişliğine rağmen çok çok kötü bir
örnektir aynı işi yapar direktör
seviyesinde yükselir daha fazla da
yükselmez genelde kadın Eee bazen yarı
ücrete falan çalışır aynı işi yapan bir
önceki erkek yönetici erkek direktöre
kıyasla ve bu kabullenilmiş
şimdi borsa
İstanbul'da 475 tane şirketimiz var
bunların yönetim kurulu olmak zorunda
açık olmak zorunda isimleri web
sitelerinde onun için de istatistik
almak
mümkün burada kadın yönetim kurulu
üyesi oranı %
17,5 altıda bir yani her 5 yönetim
kurulu erkek üyeye Bir tane kadın
düşüyor şimdi buradan toparlar Ken bu
istatistikler Bir taraftan da süreye
bakıyorum süre hızlı geçiyor Tabii ben %
katılıyorum yor Hayat kendi hayatımda
çalıştığım ortamlarda biz erkeklerin
güçlü olduğu taraflar olduğu kadar
Mesela biz acelecidir iş dünyasında
biraz Kumar gibi karar alabiliriz
e bazen de işte çok hızlı karar alıp
uygulamak gerektiği için kadın seçicidir
daha güvenli yolu takip etmek
isteyebilir risk alma iştahı kapasitesi
biraz daha düşüktür o açıdan eee burada
çok büyük bir potansiyel olduğunu
düşünüyorum elimde başka istatistikler
de var ama tabii zamanımız yetmeyecek
Ama şunu bağlamak için şunu söylemek
istiyorum kriz dönemlerinde pandemi iyi
bir dönem bir iki çalışma e okudum
e bayağı rakamlarla Ortaya koymuş veri
şunu gösteriyor öğrenme kapasitesi
kadında daha yüksek Çünkü sabırla ilgili
Detay gerektiren ki Arge biraz öyle bir
iş sanırım ama
Arge ve akademisyenlerin kadın ağırlıklı
olacak olması yakın dönemde Bence
Türkiye için çok büyük bir umut Çünkü
kadın Böylelikle yüz binlerce öğrenciye
dokunacak yetiştirecek Eee mezun edecek
aynı zamanda çocukların kendi
çocuklarının eğitiminde kadının
ağırlıklı bir rolü var O açıdan kadına
yapılan yatırımın çok kıymetli olduğunu
düşünüyorum Bir de sosyal medyada
yazıyorum ama bu vesileye de söylemek
istiyorum şimdi mesela
Türkiye voleybol milli takımımız
kadınlarda değil mi hepimiz voleybolcu
olduk Aslında Eskiden izliyor muyduk
bilmiyorum ama başarı çok önemli bir şey
başarı çok
ölçülebilir Bazen çok sert bir şey
başarılı başarısız Biz girişimcilikte
ona başarısız demiyoruz deneyim diyoruz
ama işte sporda başka alanlarda çok
belirleyici oluyor Son 20 maçı
kazanmışlar ve en büyük iki kupayı
kazanmışlar 3üncü en büyük kupa
Olimpiyatlar orada da iyi gidiyor Durum
seçilecek ve geçen yıl Gelecek yıl e
Umarım iyi şeyler yapacaklar size şu
düşünceyi bırakmak istiyorum
Acaba bu kadar Medya olarak harcama
olarak kaynak olarak Odak olarak futbola
ayırdığımız eski bir futbolcu olarak
söylüyorum futbola ayırdığımız
kaynağın çeyreğini alıp bu tarafa
aktarsan Acaba neyi başarabilir di beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim